Whales Don’t Spray Water Out of Their Blowholes
Myth: Whales spray water out of their blowholes.
Contrary to what you may have seen in such
movies as Pixar’s otherwise extremely entertaining
Finding Nemo, whales don’t spray water out
of their blowholes.
Further, the whale’s trachea doesn’t connect
to the esophagus of the whale; so when Dory
and Marlin went down the whale’s throat,
in real life, they’d have simply been eaten.
(Another interesting thing about Finding Nemo
is that when the mother died, the father would
have turned into a female and become the mother-
clownfish are all born male with the dominate
male of a group becoming female when the female
of the group dies.
Also, Coral, Marlin’s wife, should have
been bigger than Marlin, not smaller as depicted
in the movie.)
Whales, of course, are mammals that live in
the ocean, but scientists believe that whales
were once land mammals that adapted to live
in the sea, likely because the sea held a
more bountiful supply of food than the land
did at the time that they made the switch.
Whatever the case, when whales inhale, they
flex a muscle which opens the blowhole and
take in a big gulp of air.
Then, they relax the muscle to close the blowhole,
leaving them free to dive down beneath the
surface of the water once more without drowning
themselves.
It’s exhaling that’s the interesting part.
When the whale resurfaces, they have to release
the used up air back into the atmosphere just
like all other mammals do.
This results in a spout, but it isn’t water
(at least not at first).
The air inside the whale is typically quite
warm from the whale’s body heat.
When it’s exhaled, it meets the much cooler
temperature of the air outside and immediately
condenses, making it look like a spout of
water.
(This is also often mixed with mucus —it
is a nose, after all!)
The great thing for avid whale watchers is
that every species of whale has a differently
shaped blowhole (some even have two!) which
results in differently shaped spouts.
Because of this, an experienced whale watcher
can tell what species of whale is nearby just
by seeing their spouts.
For instance, a humpback whale’s spout looks
like a column; orcas’ spouts are somewhat
more bushy; and gray whales’ two blowholes
are positioned in such a way that their exhalation
results in something of a heart-shaped spout.
As a rule, baleen whales—those whales who
don’t have teeth, but rather have baleen
plates to filter food out of the water—have
two blowholes, while toothed whales have just
one blowhole.
Types of baleen whales include the humpback,
blue, and gray whales.
(This is, of course, another inaccuracy in
Finding Nemo as that was a humpback whale
that they showed having only one blowhole.)
Meanwhile, toothed whales include sperm whales
and beluga whales, among others.
Interestingly, the blowhole of a sperm whale
is actually located on its left side rather
than right on top of its head.
It’s technically a “left nostril.”
While they don’t have a right nostril, they
do have a right nasal passage that is fully
developed; it just lacks an opening.
Luckily for whales, they don’t have to keep
coming up for air every few minutes like we’d
have to.
Sperm whales, for instance, can hold their
breath for about an hour and a half.
Part of their ability to stay underwater so
long comes down to the size of their lungs
which are, as you can imagine, pretty large
(to give you an idea, a blue whale’s lung
capacity is 5000 litres, or 1320 gallons).
However, it also has to do with the way whales
are able to process the air that goes in.
It’s estimated that whales use about 90%
of the oxygen that enters their lungs, making
the most of each breath.
In comparison, humans are estimated to use
only about 15% of the oxygen we breathe.
Bonus Facts:
• Another whale of an error in Finding Nemo
is when they depict the humpback whale as
having a uvula- whales don’t have those.
• “Mr. Ray” in Finding Nemo was depicted
as a female, lacking claspers used for mating.
• Dory and Marlin should have never been
able to encounter an angler fish, as they
are found in depths of greater than 1,000
meters- an environment the stalwart pair could
not have survived in.
• After a female clownfish lays her eggs,
neither she nor the male fish that fertilized
the eggs have anything further to do with
their offspring.
• An episode of Seinfeld features Kramer
accidentally hitting a golf ball into a whale’s
blowhole—a “blowhole in one.”
The whale washes up on shore and George has
to pretend to be a marine biologist to save
it by simply plucking the ball out of the
blowhole.
This would have been impossible, trained marine
biologist or not.
First off, a golf ball likely wouldn’t have
been an obstruction, as it would have landed
atop the nasal plug used to keep seawater
out during dives, and then blasted off when
the whale exhaled.
If somehow it did get past the nasal plug,
it’s doubtful the whale would have tolerated
George sticking his whole arm in and even
if it did, his arm wouldn’t have fit into
the nasal cavity and into the larnyx, nor
would a golf ball likely be big enough to
block the larnyx.
If one did get down that far, the whale would
simply eject it, according to marine biologist
Dr. Joy Reidenberg.
(For reference, humpback whales can sneeze
air at over 300 mph, which would have shot
that golf ball out quicker than Kramer hit
it, even if sucked in.)
Finally, the whale depicted was a baleen whale,
meaning it had two nostrils so if one nostril
was clogged, they could still breathe.
• As a consequence of the fact that the
whale’s trachea and esophagus are not connected,
it’s next to impossible for them to choke
on food, unless they somehow suck something
in through their blowhole that they can’t
get out.
• If whales have to breathe consciously,
how do they sleep?
They can’t fall fully asleep because they
wouldn’t get up to breathe otherwise.
Instead, they allow one half of the brain
to sleep at a time.
That way, they’re able to rest but can also
make the decision to go up for air when necessary.